What puts you in the mood for, you know…..
Is it oysters?
Chocolate?
What about weed?
The pot smoker stereotype is pretty ingrained in popular culture.
They are depicted as lazy, unmotivated, sleepy.
Nothing that really screams, “filled with
crazy sexual desire.”
And these headlines from a few years ago would
agree with that: I mean, marijuana is obviously
bad for your sex life.
But fast forward to 2017 and the
opposite now seems to be true.
So, if you’re looking to increase your sex
drive: which is it?
Should you be hitting the joint or passing
it along?
Dr. Michael Eisenberg, an assistant professor
of urology at Stanford University wanted to
answer this question for his many patients
who were concerned that smoking weed was leading
to problems in the bedroom.
What he found was that both men and women
who self-reported as being daily marijuana
users had sex more often than those who abstained
from marijuana use completely.
His study took data from the CDC-sponsored
National Survey of Family Growth.
More than 28,000 women and nearly 23,000 men
were asked a number of questions about their
relationship status and daily habits, including their use of marijuana and how often they had sex.
The women who used marijuana daily had sex
an average of 7.1 times in the four weeks
leading up to the survey.
This is compared to the six times for women
who did not partake in marijuana use.
For men, daily marijuana smokers got down
and dirty an average of 6.9 times, get it?
Compared to the 5.6 times of abstainers.
These findings remained true across age, race,
education, income level, and marital status,
but the study focused primarily on heterosexual
sex.
Before you get out those rolling papers, though,
let’s take a closer look.
The data from this paper is limited.
For one, it fails to indicate if the participants
had THC, the active ingredient in marijuana,
in their system while having sex.
I mean someone could easily smoke or consume THC in the morning and have it out of their system
by the time they got home and were in the mood for romance.
The study mostly just shows a positive correlation
between those who smoke weed daily and how
many times that person has sex, without providing
any real basis for a cause and effect relationship
between the two.
And Dr. Eisenberg himself said that this is
a case of correlation and not causation.
He just hopes that the positive association
will prompt more research on the subject rather
than be the definitive guide to marijuana
use and sex.
But unfortunately, it can be really difficult
to study marijuana’s effects on our physiology,
especially in the U.S.
This is because it it still considered a Schedule
1 drug by the Drug Enforcement Agency.
This puts it in the same category as heroin
and ecstasy and means that it is very hard
to use it for research purposes.
But there’s been some research.
And spoiler: it’s about to get weird.
One small study published in 2010 in the journal
European Urology did find that THC could cause
sexual dysfunction for men.
The researchers found that the penis muscle
from five male patients and six rhesus monkeys
had receptors for THC.
And upon further examination, the THC seemed to have an inhibitory effect on the said penis muscle.
But wait, there’s more.
For weed and sex-loving women, there is also
some bad news, according to physician and
author Dr. Julie Holland.
Dr. Holland says that something comparable
to cotton mouth can happen to your vagina
after you smoke marijuana since it dries similar
mucus membranes in both regions.
That said, not all strains will do this and
not all women will experience the same effects.
So, there’s that.
But in general, there are very few studies
on marijuana and the body, including how it
relates to sexual experiences, and most of
the information we have is entirely based
on anecdotal experiences.
So while the current study did show a correlation
between sex drive and smoking weed, headlines
like these might be getting a little too excited.
So smoking weed maybe kind of increases your sex drive, but you know what weed definitely does?
Make you want to binge on a bunch of videos.
Check out this one from our friends at Now This Nerd, it’s all about the history of Thor's costume.
I mean if you’re like me and you love comics, you’re gonna really like it.
Don’t forget to subscribe to us, and make
sure to keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.